all right so Sasha we just got this new
script it's really great I think you're
really gonna like it it's like nothing
you've ever done before I really think
it's a good fit for you yeah what's it
about basically you walk up to most
people you find and insult them and
demean their religion or race or
heritage yeah I can do that The Dictator
stars Sacha Baron Cohen and Anna Faris I
really like Sasha Baron Cohen I think
he's a really good actor he's very
talented and it's not just because he
can be that really offensive guy who
just makes fun of like things that you
would never imagine saying in real life
but he actually is a very talented actor
he was terrific in Hugo I thought he was
excellent I'm hearing that he might play
Freddie Mercury the singer of Queen that
is gold the dictator he plays this
really just exaggerated leader like this
you know Saddam Hussein Osama bin Laden
mak'st like you know flat-out comedy
like if a guy messes up in any possible
way he will have him executed
if you say the wrong thing to him he
will have you executed but our story
really picks up when he goes to America
to make this speech he gets kidnapped
his beard gets shaved off and he gets
forced into just American community and
he has to find out how to survive in
America no one really recognizes him as
this dictator and he thinks that he can
just treat everyone the same way on a
ferris plays this owner of this
completely green supermarket she is
completely against racism bigotry in all
aspects like he can't even make the
slightest little joke to her and he gets
a job there which creates for a lot of
interesting situations now I'm extremely
hard to offend like seriously I rarely
ever get offended this movie didn't
offend me at all I just didn't really
laugh that much I didn't find the movie
that funny I like Sasha Baron Cohen I
like his style of humor it just says
something about this movie didn't work
for me and I was really trying to think
what it was and I figured it out
basically this movie is like Borat or
Bruno it's where he just kind of walks
up to people and finds some really
strange thing to improv about except
they scripted it you know they scripted
it more they gave it a plot a backstory
a central romance and they tried to make
it into an actual movie unless the
documentary style but it's the same
director as Borat and Bruno and
obviously the same star it was really
clear to me that there was something
lost there because they're trying to
emulate those previous two ways of
making a movie but they're also trying
to make a movie with a story and that
really didn't work for me literally
everyone in this movie that has any
comedic chops just falls under Sacha
Baron Cohen's reign because he
he's just owning like every scene I mean
he's like kind of owning the scenes like
he doesn't really let anyone else shine
on Affairs I think is very funny and
very talented her entire job this movie
is basically react to things that Sasha
Baron Cohen says and I was a little bit
disappointed with that because I would
like to have seen more comedic chemistry
between those two and I didn't really
feel it because I kind of just seemed
like he would enter a scene look around
and find the most offensive or excessive
thing to do which was funny from time to
time but there was a lot of times this
movie I laughed to me that's easy humor
it's very easy to make those types of
jokes I like humor that's more clever
that maybe makes you think a little bit
more but it's not that I don't like
sophomoric humor
I am totally fine at laughing at a fart
joke or poop joke or some guy getting
smacked in the head or something
and for the first like probably 20
minutes to this movie I was like this is
pretty funny actually consistently but
after like the 15th black joke it's just
not funny anymore and like I said I'm
not offended by that it's just after a
while it gets old just didn't seem like
they are working for the humor and the
story was just so uninteresting that
being said though Sacha Baron Cohen is a
very talented actor he's a very talented
comedian he's funny in this movie is
funny just kind of seemed like that ship
has passed and I think they realized
that with Bruno so they tried to
incorporate like a film it wasn't just
like a documentary style but they're
basically doing the same thing as Bruno
and Borat I'd like to see him do
something different so since I like
Sasha Baron Cohen and I did laughs in
this movie I'm going to get the dictator
a C+ it's by no means a terrible or bad
movie it's just kind of in the middle
for me but you should see the dictator
if you're a fan of his previous works or
a fan of Sacha Baron Cohen in general
you'll probably enjoy the movie at least
a little bit until next time guys if you
like this review you can subscribe to my
channel and get stuck man I
you